Hello everybody. Hope that you are good.
I'm sure that you are because the
projection is playing out. Okay, you can
see how they came
to the mid-range here. Okay, I was
telling you guys long long candles.
Okay, check this candle long candle they
retrace long candle they retrace long
candle they retrace long green candle
they retrace again here it happened.
Okay, it keeps happening.
So that's what we're saying that is very
likely that we retest the mid-range
before a continuation to the upside to
fill
well to retrace this liquidity pool here
to the upside. Okay, then you can see
that they just retrace this liquidity
pool during the Asian session. But
I was telling you in Twitter
before
I uploaded this video
that you know, the problem is that we
had a week here. Okay, let me remove all
of this mess.
The liquidity pool and I'll remove that.
I'm also going to remove all these
levels here of the range. Okay, and you
can see that here we have a week.
You know, so any of you
that took a long to the liquidity pool
that will be your take profits. Now I
know some of you
shorted at the liquidity pool. Okay,
then when you see this week or when you
saw my tweet telling you that there was
a week to the upside. That's when you
have to take profits. Okay, because when
there is a week at the highest price
tends to come back to it. Okay, before
going before continuing going lower. So
the 50% of the week is filled now. It
was around 31k. There you you see it.
It's being filled
and now if we if we check the range now
you can see that we are facing some
resistance here. Okay, you can see this
was resistance resistance resistance and
now we are at resistance. Okay, so let's
see how this plays out. Now today is
Friday and you guys know that I don't
trade on weekends because there is
usually no much liquidity and you
usually don't see big moves. Okay, so
this projection is probably going to
postpone for next week, but today
we have PCE data, okay? And that is in 6
minutes, so we're going to see how the
market reacts to it. Uh now, let me tell
you something, okay?
It's as simple as this. If price if if
this um hang on.
If this
1-hour candle
can close with a candle body
above 30,950,
okay? Then, you can favor the idea,
you know, to revisit the highs, probably
do a deviation, and that and if we do a
deviation and come back inside this
range, then this is when you open
shorts, okay? You don't open shorts here
because then you are at risk that price
continues going higher, okay? And then
you're going to be uh stopped. All
right? So, this uh short trigger would
be to see
a deviation here,
okay? And then as as soon as you are
inside this range
and you consolidate here,
then you can open shorts and you're
going to target the range lows, okay?
And the range lows is at 29,600-ish.
All right? That's my plan if we can
close this candle this 1-hour candle
above this uh resistance zone, okay? Uh
now, PCI data is in 5 minutes. Let's
have a look at Forex Factory. We are now
in Forex Factory. I don't know if you
guys know this website. I usually use
Forex Factory and Forex Live, okay? To
see the calendar with the news
announcement. So,
uh you have here that the main events
for today is the uh GDP in Canada and of
course in USA the PCE data. All right?
You can see here the previous, the
forecast, and the actual that's going to
be revealed in 30 minutes, okay? So,
we're going to see how the market reacts
to it, but you have to remember that
Bitcoin has a reverse correlation with
the dollar. That means that the dollar
index goes up, Bitcoin is going to go
down.
And if the dollar index goes down,
Bitcoin is going to go up, okay? Now,
this data, the PCE data, is correlated
with the dollar. Okay? What does this
mean? This means that if they're
expecting the forecast 0.3%, okay? If
you get anything higher than 0.3%, if
you get 0.4%, 0.5%, then the dollar
index is going to go up and Bitcoin is
going to go down, okay? So, that would
be bad news for Bitcoin. But,
if you get 0.3%, that should be priced
in, okay? But, if you get lower than
0.3%, so if you get 0. 2% for example,
then that would be good news for
Bitcoin. And then, you could consider
the idea that you're going to see price
going higher, okay? Probably
um
going above the previous high because
that's going to add fuel to the chart.
Um in the opposite uh case,
if the PCE data is higher than 0.4%, if
it's 0.5%, 0.6%, then
this is going to be the top for Bitcoin,
okay? The local top for Bitcoin. So,
let's see what happens in 1 minute and a
half.
Um to be honest,
we're going to go now through the next
week because today is Friday, so I can
uh I can do this. So, okay, the
Saturday, Sunday, nothing going on here.
All right, Monday. What do we have in
Monday? Uh not really ISM manufacturing
PMI. All right.
That usually uh I don't look at that
much. Then, July 4th, that's a bank
holiday in USA, so don't expect much
volatility during this day, okay? This
is a day that during the New York
session, you can take some time off
because you're not going to see much
going on on the charts, okay? In
principle, that's on Tuesday. All right?
Now, Wednesday. What do we have in
Wednesday? FOMC meeting minutes.
So, it's not an interest rate decision.
It doesn't work like that, okay? It's
the minutes. The minutes are only notes
that they took in the previous FOMC
meeting, all right? Now,
Thursday. What do we have in Thursday?
Uh all right.
We have unemployment claims,
PMI,
job openings. Okay, so now we have quite
a volatile day on Thursday, but on
Friday,
as it's the first Friday of the month,
we have here non-farm payrolls.
Right? This is going to be the main
event for next week.
Also, uh together with the FOMC uh
minutes, right? So, next week is going
to
have quite a volatility in principle,
except on Tuesday, okay? That's what I
can tell you in advance. Now, let's see
if they have revealed the result of the
PCE.
Let's have a look.
Um pending. Come on, tell me.
Come on.
We're going to wait a bit. There you go.
0.3%, okay? They actually said 0.3%.
That's what they uh forecasted. So, in
principle,
this should be priced in. Uh if we go
now to the chart, we're going to
probably see
uh
first a full smooth. Could be to the
downside of the that or to the upside.
That's going to get retrace, okay? That
usually happens when something is priced
in.
That you're going to see a lot of
volatility at the start,
but then that move should get reversed.
Well, that's what usually happens, okay?
Let's go now into Bitcoin. Let's have a
look. So, you have Bitcoin going up. You
can have a look now, okay? If you go
into the 5-minute time frame,
here, you can see how they're starting
to push price up, okay? Probably after
the news announcement. Now, let's go
into the dollar index, okay?
Let's have a look at the dollar index.
The dollar then, in principle, should be
going down. There it is, dollar index
going down, okay?
Check out this candle.
But again,
this I don't trust this move, okay?
Because um I'm expecting that they said
some kind of a false move
at the start, and then this move is
going to get retrace because it's going
to leave liquidity pools behind, okay?
So, it's going to leave imbalances
behind that they're going to get
recovered. That's That's I think. Um
you're going to see the opposite with
Bitcoin, okay? If the dollar index is
doing this,
okay? Then Bitcoin is going to do this.
All right? That's what I'm expecting
now. So, if you go back to Bitcoin,
let's have a look at what's going on
here.
Okay? Then you see crazy candle. This
candle doesn't make any sense, okay? You
can see
the news are out, they push price up,
and then they retrace. So, um, wait at
least another 30 minutes for the dust to
settle. That's what I suggest you to do
in these cases.
Now, let's have a look what is going on
here one-hour time frame.
What is still above this resistance
zone? Oopsies.
zone? Let's see how how they close the
candle. But, what I told you guys, if
they can manage to close the candle body
above this zone here, then we're going
to expect,
you know, price to revisit these highs,
okay? And probably
we'll see a deviation, okay? Now, in the
case, I know some of you are wondering
this, what happens if we don't see a
deviation?
Okay, it's very clear then.
Oopsies.
Then, you can see here
that that would be your next zone in the
chart, okay? And that would be the
32,400
zone that everybody is talking about,
all right? So, um, in this case,
you will be aiming at the same thing,
all right?
You could see here
another deviation. So, you have to be
alert for that, okay? If that happens.
If we come to this level,
okay? You sweep the highs and then price
comes back under, then that's another
uh, short opportunity that you can take,
okay? To the downside. But,
I might be wrong with this one, but I
don't see 32K coming.
Again,
uh, I might be very wrong with this one.
Um, if I'm wrong, I'll tell you, uh,
grow I was wrong on this one, no
problem. But, what I can see at the
moment, or what I imagine is that
either we dump from here after retracing
this liquidity pool and then filling the
wick.
That is was this one. Okay? So, this
could be a chance that we could drop
from here, or we could see or deviation
here, and then drop to the range lows.
Okay? That's what I can see at the
moment. Um again, you know,
you cannot trade based on my ideas
because I'm not giving you financial
advice. It's only my opinion. I might be
wrong.
So, you can only use it as confluence.
Okay? So, if you think the same as me,
you know, without previously uh hearing
my opinion, then, you know, you could be
more confident in your own analysis.
But, that's uh that's the only thing you
can do
after listening to my analysis. Okay?
Just don't trade based on my analysis
because uh you know, if I'm wrong, I'm
going to lose money. So, I don't want
anybody else to lose money
uh because my call. All right? That's
not what it's about. It's about
learning, guys. Okay, when I have a look
at BitMEX, check what the chart says.
Okay? The liquidation heat map. Okay, 12
hours time frame. A lot of liquidity at
30,550,
but also here, you can see that 31,350.
That's the previous highs. There's also
some liquidity. Okay? But, mostly
at 30,550.
It's not telling me that much. Okay?
Let's go to the 7-day time frame to see
if anything is more clear here.
Okay, I like this chart more.
I like this chart more.
Uh
wow. Okay. You can see that this week
hit a lot of liquidations. And there's
also a lot of liquidity uh stacked up
all the way to 31,750-ish.
Okay? What does that mean, guys?
This is
the deviation that we're looking for.
Okay? This is this liquidity here
is the deviation
above the previous high.
All right? That's what I'm looking for.
Also here,
a lot of liquidity at 29,600, which is
the range lows. All right? So, can you
Can you see now
my projection with High Block Capital
7-day time frame liquidation heat map,
okay? Sweep the highs. Hit all these
liquidations at 20 31,100
ish.
And then drop to range lows. This is
pretty much what I'm projecting. Again,
I might be wrong on this one. Um
That's That's how this trading game
works, okay? Now, 1 month time frame
I see a lot of liquidity at 31,700.
That's the same zone.
You see what I mean, guys, okay? That's
the same zone. Um to the downside
with uh no not sure if this is uh quite
uh could be true because actually like
if you go on Twitter now, you're going
to see everybody talking about new highs
going to 40K. So, yeah, I imagine that
there are a lot of longs opening
uh from all the way here and even this
zone here. Also, if you notice
this yellow bar
what it's telling you is that it's been
uh getting brighter and brighter
from here, okay? So, that's from here
from 30,000. So, in this range here what
this chart is telling you that during
this range here
there are a lot of new longs opening.
Okay?
That's what it's telling you. So,
uh yep. Uh why not this liquidity here?
Uh it might it doesn't have to be
disregarded, all right? Uh but for now,
that's what I think. Let's go back to
the 7 days time frame. I like this chart
the best.
Um you can see
that really above 31,800
there is not that much liquidity showing
in the chart, okay? That's what I'm
telling you, guys. I'm looking for that
deviation
if it's possible and then targeting the
range lows. So, anyway, guys, this is
pretty much everything that I wanted to
say in this video.
Today is Friday. We have the weekend
around the corner. And you know, it's
what I'm telling you, guys. I try to not
trade much during the weekend. Uh stay
still because that's usually when you
are going to lose the profits that
you've made during the week, okay? Well,
that's at least in my experience. That's
why trade
on the weekend. If I trade on the
weekends,
then I'm going to focus on altcoins,
okay? Because that's usually when you
see more volatility.
All right?
Now,
uh the Bitcoin chart, I'm still looking
for that um momentum pivot, okay?
Because now, you can see the momentum is
not pivoting yet to the downside, all
right? So, there is no reason here to
open uh swing shorts. Uh now, this zone,
as I told you, this liquidity pool that
we've just filled,
here, let me mark it for you.
This liquidity pool here
was a reason, a zone to open shorts.
Now, the problem is that we had this
wick here. The wick has been filled,
okay? So, let's see how price reacts to
this because now, if we start coming
below this um
this zone here, okay? Then, you can
start to see price going down. And, of
course, you know, if we close this
1-hour candle above this zone, and price
continues making higher moves, then
we're going to look for that deviation
above these highs, okay? To look for
shorts as long as we are back inside the
range, okay? So, that's what we're going
to look for, okay? I still think that um
the chart is telling me that the market
maker is building his shorts.
Might be wrong with this one, but
going to the 1-hour time frame, tell me
what you see. I'll tell you what I see.
I see large green candles here, here,
here, here, here, here, more, okay? A
wick. This means to me that they are
pushing price up to build their shorts
at the higher zones, okay? You can see,
okay?
And then they drop. They build their
shorts, they drop. They build their
shorts, they drop. All right? That's
what I think. So,
uh to me, the best entry point would be
if you can see a deviation here,
and then come back inside the range.
This is where I'll be opening uh my
shorts, not here, because I don't want
the risk to price continue higher and
breaking out of this range.
Okay?
Um, so that's pretty much everything
that I see in the chart right now at the
moment. Be careful, guys. Today is
Friday. Um, only trade during the New
York session. As long as the New York
session finishes,
get out of the chart, okay? Take your
money.
All right? And enjoy the weekend.
Before I finish the video and say
goodbye to you guys, I wanted to say
that if you support the content, of
course, you can give a like, a comment,
a subscribe. That's good for the
algorithm, so the video shows to other
users in YouTube. But also, of course,
you can register with the referral link
in the description in Bitget, okay? It's
an exchange that doesn't require KYC
unless if you are in the US, uh, Canada,
or Singapore, I think. Uh, you get $5
bonus when you log in. Also, if you
deposit at least $100, you're going to
participate in, uh, the next giveaways
of the trading course. Also,
um, deposits over $200 get 10% payback.
That means that you, for example,
uh, deposit, let's say, $500, then
you're going to get $50 back. And of
course, you know, if you depo- if you
deposit bigger amounts, then you get
bigger rewards, okay? Bigger pay- bigger
paybacks. All right? Um, also, for the
guys in the UK,
there is an event going on at the
moment, okay? It's a raffle. Um, to
participate, you know, it's very simple
tasks uh, that are easy to to achieve.
And, uh, these are the awards you can
get: one Bitcoin, Messi merchandising
bag, copycat bag, a sports kit, two
English Premier League tickets for
August, $2 of trading bonuses, $10 of
trading bonuses, okay? So, uh, that's
pretty much, uh, everything, guys. Thank
you, Bitget, for sponsoring the content,
also. And I'll see you soon.